1936 MHz boost clock in OC mode 8 plus2
Super alloy power phase design Auto
extreme technology GPU controled fan
headers and uh AA RGB lighting I
[Music]
guess tunnel bear is the simple VPN app
that makes it easy to browse privately
and enjoy a more open internet to try
tunnel bear for free check out the link
in the video description so the strix
1080 from Asus is finally here and it's
rocking an allnew aesthetic cover to
their beloved Drex C3 cooler design I
think it looks great and I appreciate
that they opted to go with a flat black
coloring essentially everywhere which
will joking about RGB being an overdone
feature aside complement the addition of
these greatl looking Aura enabled RGB
LEDs that support many different
lighting modes and can sync with other
Ora enabled devices like your a use
motherboard keyboard mouse Etc as well
for connectivity Asus decided to switch
it up a bit instead of the 1080s
standard setup of three display ports
one HDMI connector and one DVI connector
Asus opted to ditch one of those display
ports for an additional HDMI connector
they call this solution vrf friendly
HDMI ports which might sound kind of
like SLI ready Edition Ram but it's not
that bad all it means is that you can
have an HDMI based VR headset that
connected and some other HDMI device
like a monitor or TV without using a
display port adapter for the flat panel
display something that's required with
the HCC Vive on the 1000 series Nvidia
cards due to their shockingly poor
implementation of HDMI over display port
that's it moving on the STX has a 203
MHz overclock in OC mode over the
founders Edition 1733 MHz boost clock
this results in a freakishly awesome
final clock speed of 1936 MHz which
hovers in real games between around
1920 to slightly over
2,63 MHz thanks to GPU boost there is an
elephant in the room here however the OC
mode isn't enabled out of the box and
there's no Hardware bios switch or
anything to turn it on all the 6970 back
in the day it has to be enabled through
GPU tweak 2 and a sous software utility
problem number one this utility isn't
that easy to find searching for download
GPU tweak 2 does yield an auss download
page but for a horribly out-of-date
version of the software no if you want
it you'll need to scroll a little
further to the Reddit discussion thread
on how to find it now they aren't hiding
it either there's a graphic about it on
the box Ard and honestly it's not that
hard to track down if you just go to
your graphics card support page select
the drivers button expand exp what
operating system you have then expand
the utility section it's right there no
big deal the confusing part is this why
if the tool is required to reach the
performance levels advertised are they
not in your face about it if this is
what enables the card to be awesome tell
me I mean sure in the manual it says to
install the driver's disc but like come
on lonus basically made a meme out of
throwing those things away back in 2009
we have a driver disc don't use this
download the L off the Nvidia website
they're inherently outdated and Asus is
a pretty smart Bunch I'd imagine they
know as well as I do that the majority
of people ignore them and go straight to
Nvidia or amd's website for the most
up-to-date drivers why would they ever
find themselves on the Asus support page
it's annoying too because this problem
is so simple to fix MSI has an easy to
find download page for afterburner so
apparently it's not impossible and a
surprisingly low number of people are
overclocking their cards anyways so
shouldn't you be just giving the
performance to them that you're saying
the card can do anyways right out of the
box I mean the card sits at 66°
underload not a big deal and you clearly
have a bios that will run these speeds
by default there was that whole Scandal
where you were sending out cards
pre-loaded with it to reviewers so
instead of taking that away from
reviewers FYI our card was reflashed
with the retail bios before testing just
give it to everyone problem solved maybe
I'm missing something but enough of that
let's move on the performance side of
things was actually pretty groovy I
experienced performance improvements of
about 3 to 7 FPS across the board which
is rather awesome and that's while these
games are running at 4K with everything
maxed out beyond their maximum presets
that 3 to FPS was clawed for these were
in very difficult scenarios if if I
turned all the settings down so the
average FPS number was higher the FPS
that it would have climbed would have
also been higher I don't expect many
people to pick the highest possible
performance preset and then crank
further beyond that this card is a beast
and will serve you well and all of that
while sitting at about
66° and nice and quietly too the card is
a beast that doesn't get too hot and
doesn't get too loud that's cool so it's
a rocking performer out of the box
just don't expect it to overclock beyond
the GPU tweak OC mode I found this
rather surprising I mean to be fair I
did manage to get the card stable at
around plus 25 MHz but we're talking
like 1% here for that level of increase
what's the point I just turned it off
and to be fair having the card hit 263
mahz or 2 GHz was impressive enough it's
just a little surprising that there was
no juice left left in the tank they
really did seem to cut it close you can
either be frustrated by this or you
could take that as a good thing they did
all the work for you let me know what
your feelings are in the comment section
down below so in conclusion despite my
objections to the way it was advertised
this is an absolutely stunning card it
looks beautiful in so many ways I love
the swap to dual HDMI ports and it is
fast as hell I might see some personal
rig potential here so stay tuned for
that
today we're highlighting the k7xx
limited edition ruby red headphones
which is unlike any of the colors that
is currently on me of course Mast drop
still has a bunch of other cool products
which you can check out at the link in
the video description hopefully you guys
know about Mast drop already though it's
the pretty simple concept where the more
people buy something on mass drop a
certain product the lower the price of
that certain product goes the product
we're showcasing today is the same spec
wise as the k7xx headphones that lus
reviewed last year can check with that
video right up here the only real
difference is that it uses red accents
on the ear cups and headband and that's
about it other than the fact that it is
a limited edition drop so if you want a
pair you're going to have to act pretty
fast so if you want to check them out
and grab a pair of ruby red k7xx
headphones head over to the link in the
video description today thanks for
watching guys if this video sucked you
know what to do but if it was awesome
and you're like wow all that stuff is
weird but it's a pretty cool graphics
card regardless hit the like button get
subscribed or check out the link in the
video description
to buy the stuff that we mentioned in
this video like the 1080 stricks at
Amazon and also Link in the description
is our merch store where you can buy
cool shirts and our community Forum
where you can talk about stuff like why
don't they have that easier to set up or
ra I don't care the cards really good
and I do manual overclocking anyway so I
don't need that thing uh I don't know
check out this video to see like the
normal GTX 1080 I filmed it in a little
bit of a weird exotic area so check that
out